California's governor Gavin Newson
coming under Fire for his latest claims
promoting his State while attacking
Republican leaders in red States
California has has been well Freedom's
Force multiplier protecting Liberty from
a rising tide of Oppression more than
any people in any place
California has bridged the historical
expanse between freedom for some
and freedom for all here's one guy used
to live there his name is Dave Rubin he
now lives in Florida in the associated
the Reuben report Dave good morning to
you uh you saw the story what you think
man Gavin Newsom cannot say one single
word of truth if his life depended on it
bill I did a little homework before the
show today I'm bringing I'm bringing I'm
bringing receipts do you know how many
people have left California in the last
three years because I actually checked
the numbers 275
000 in 2020. 360
000 in 2021 340
000 in 2022 that's 975
000 people in three years I carried the
one and did all the work on that to
double check it so 975 000 people flee
California because they were fleeing his
tyranny his high taxes his lockdowns his
mandates let's not forget he was also
the former mayor of San Francisco uh
what he did to that city is now has been
exported throughout the state 800
000 people have moved here to the free
state of Florida which is absolutely
flourishing it was also announced I
think yesterday California now has a 20
55 billion dollar deficit of Florida of
course has a surplus so the proof is in
the pudding I mean you don't have to do
too much digging where are people
leaving and where are they going and
that's how you know who's doing it right
and who's doing it right I appreciate
the math good homework there uh Dave two
things here singer Phil Labonte uh lives
in well here's what he said on screen
number one guys hi New Hampshire
resident here I don't pay income tax to
my state I don't need permission to
carry a firearm I can collect rain water
and we have way less crime we are the
free state thank you very much found
this thing from Arrow Weber a
cinematographer I think he lives in
California he said uh the harm reduction
centers throughout California
um sent out a a video of
San Francisco officials giving away free
bags of needles and paraphernalia to
drug addicts and tagged it by saying
this is California under Gavin Newsom so
I you know
pick what you want there
right well it's as simple as that look I
love the fact that now New Hampshire and
Florida and Texas and Tennessee and
South Dakota we're all competing now for
the free estate those are also all the
states that people are moving to the
simple truth is you cannot if you were a
young person saying I want to go ahead
and start a good life a decent life as
an American citizen how could you do
that in California how can you open a
business in California with high taxes
and high regulation also knowing the
government could come lock you down at
any moment and have all sorts of crazy
regulations related to who you hire and
all the diversity stuff and everything
else you simply cannot do it there but
you can move to some of the states that
I just mentioned where you will have
every opportunity I mean let's not
forget I'm here in Miami where our mayor
Francis Suarez he put out a tweet about
a year and a half ago saying how can I
help when he heard that all these tech
people wanted to leave California well
now they've left and Miami has become
the Silicon Valley what silica promise
of Silicon Valley is happening right
here in Miami while in San Francisco you
know the old Silicon Valley it's it's
drug dens and rampant crime and and just
the general statement a lot of work to
do too I know why you left Dave's thanks
for coming back and sharing your story
with us today good math I'm going to
bring my Abacus next time Bill right on
looking forward to that enjoy Miami Dave
Rubin thank you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell